conversation  matters  because if we can't talk about it we  can't solve it and i really believe that  like when we  think about the existential problems  that we face individually culturally  socially politically economically the  solutions to these problems  begin and end with conversation  if we can't talk about it we can't solve  it we're in a situation right now where  there has been a denigration a  dissolution in healthy discourse and if  there's one thing that i'm devoted to in  this podcast it's  endeavoring to have healthy  conversations  about things that matter  because we do need to talk about these  things and the solution does lie in  conversation it's not the whole thing  but if we can't have a conversation  about these important subjects we're in  no position to  rectify the problems that we face